uh thanks for visiting my talk my name
is Dave and I will present you
[Music]
um a portable emfi attacks
um it's also an introductory talk into
emfi edit and
um it's supposed to help you get started
even if you're new to this topic and
compared to other talks you get like 0
to 100 into EMF is
especially on a budget
um first I will start with the
motivation for this why even do all this
trouble
then I will introduce both injection and
email fi to you
and then the main part will be the setup
how to build it and how to run it
in an affordable manner
and in the end I will show that the
setup works and on actual recent and
relevant targets
um
so
nowadays we have modern security
features and many chips even the very
cheapest chips
and this the question is started make
blessing index of the lead
um what I mean with this are like
connecting a jteg debugger
um or simply reading out the memory that
way or
just replacing the ROM modifying the the
memory and indeed like we have nowadays
glossy backwards we have secure boot we
have flash encryption which can make the
attacks um
more difficult but not obsolete it's
just an extra layer to get through until
you can then do the same methods you
would do before
um
yes
[Music]
so how to bypass these methods
um that's fault injection for you so
um you can do different types of Earth
injection which then allow you to skip
an instruction like a check for a secure
boot you can have fuses and you have to
read those right and then when you have
the result from the radar fuses you can
just ignore the result
um
yeah the field is relatively new so many
devices have no control measures against
emfi or other types of fault injection
and the whole setup is not really
something you can you find in one place
open source really available and
accessible some tools are very expensive
other tools are accessible but then you
have to add some custom components
always to make it a whole system right
so my idea was to make a reproducible
system for everyone to build
first of all let's take a step back um
what is emfi or what injection as I said
before in pulse injection you introduce
a fault in the system
you might remember if you have like
these ideas of safety in Aerospace
or in general you have solar rays which
can affect systems and these are faults
right and we want to try to do this in a
controlled manner to get the outcome
that we want
very specific outcome in usual cases
um and of course you have the software
port injection like raw hammer and this
type of stuff where you export the
hardware and you you and use Hardware
close to some soft metrics you you have
physical injection which is what we're
doing here
um this means that your code can be
super secure it can be perfectly written
you can have all the checks in the world
you can have users you can have whatever
you want
when you get the chip in the lab and you
modify it from the outside
there's not much you can do about it
emfi in particular leverages
electromagnetic pulses that are placed
exactly on top of an SOC
and
I think I'm the first one who is quoting
a 19th century textbook at this
conference
but the principle is like just sits like
not not that special it's uh you have
Paradise laws and you have magnetic
fields
um
and magnetic fields that move across
each other and use currents and you do
this very localized we can affect very
specific areas of the chip in very
specific
instructions or memory regions or
registers even
um
Yeah by affecting the transistor
Behavior like leaping a bit or skipping
in instructions uh you modify the
program flow even though the the code is
actually secure
um
yes so uh in the picture again it's like
just the modern version of The
Experiment on the left
where you have on the left you have a
battery connected the coil which forms
an electromagnet and then according to
the right hand rule it forms a magnetic
field in the Z direction and you move
this electromagnetic field through
another coil and then it reduces enough
current to power an amp
um so there are possibility for Comic
mitigations but they typically require a
harbor revision change
you need a new component or a new board
at least
um the upside for vendors I guess is
that the impact is limited since you
don't need Hardware access to the device
and
yeah but for us it's well suited because
we're trying to do camera research very
often and if it's all locked down and
you don't have the firmware this can
help us to bypass checks and uh
here's uh just one more example with
some pseudocode usually of course we
look at assembly but let's say we have a
static variable or a static bit or
something like this
which is set to pause when it's red we
can pause it and maybe intrusions true
or when it's checked here
um either the evaluation of the
statement your debug enable is true
it wants to go into the branch
instructions and we skip the branch
instruction or yeah also we could modify
the static variable in memory
um
the for mfi Boss you need a good timing
and put the location
you need the right instruction of course
so you need the right Delay from a
certain known signal like a boot time
and also you need to find the affected
SOC area which you can pause
um
and just so you have a picture of the
time scale we're talking about by using
a fpga for timing we have 400 meters
clock so it's a 200 and a half
nanosecond step size
[Music]
um
this is fine for many targets and if
you're a pasta you might need a faster
clock or motorized
um to discover the timing or for default
you need either to look at the code or
binary reverse engineered binary you can
also use power traces
and see where the where the code is
happening that you want to glitch
or when it is happening
here you can also see
that an example where we have a reset
line we take the Dozen input then we
have the delay that we have to figure
out of course
when the delay has passed we trigger the
emfi device
and yeah we need to be able to really
time this very accurately to get the
reducibility and also the password this
well also something you want to fine
tune
um the setup consists of these devices
it's really not that much you think
about it
you can position your mfi pulser by hand
but you really want to do it vertically
probably and the positioning platform as
I will show later can be quite cheap so
I don't see a reason not to use one
then you want to generate the right
delay which you can see the fpga here
then you have different choices of emfi
pulsers which are triggered by the delay
generator and the device under test
which should give you which should give
the delay generator the input to create
the timing the timing could also be from
a device like virus where USB so if you
trigger on a USB packet that could also
be a trigger or yeah different types of
triggers exist but wasn't this di
saying that the device on the test
triggers the delay generator
and as you can see on the right you
should make a map of your chip and
especially for sanity checking you if
you have some specific effects they
usually occur in an area and it should
be grouped
here's how it looks like in real life
everything assembled
um
so for
for positioning which is the CNC and the
other components I showed before
um
here's a close-up so you don't need that
peak of a positioning platform because
of course it only has to have as much
text and drive travel as the size of the
Chip And
um you want to mount it securely
and can't start
um for the positioning platform you have
a few options
um cncs or 3D printers are very good
idea because they are like net and mass
production and they're quite cheap they
are also used interchangeably since they
all use G-Code so everyone goes through
images and all this
um they come with the motor controllers
with the motors with the end stops with
everything you need one thing I would
like to mention is that these screws
have 10 times more backlash than belts
so
if you have the choice I would probably
um recommend it 3D printer or what you
see on the right is the drawing robot
which is probably even that one of you
because you don't need to buy the
spindle or the printhead because it's
just the positioning will put the pencil
in it
um
yeah so backlash uh just uh
in addition it means if you move the
position move away move back to it uh it
won't be perfectly accurate right and
you have last backlash that will be more
item
on the bottom you see a motorized XY
stage which is used for microscope and
such and those are much more expensive
and in my experience they offer small
benefit for the price
and on these iot targets really the CNC
was definitely enough
next up this is your delay generator I'm
using the ship.failed this stream by
this text machine
um it's open source on GitHub and it
works on the very cheapest Vigilant and
PGA the Z1 phase seven it costs 100
euros per dollars
and what I like about it is that in
theory it was made for voltage glitching
so you see
um on the on the right of this orange
dot
it's actually this Gmod adapter robots
glitching but just by changing this
component you can do emfi as well by
using this green board which I am
calling emfi companion and you can do
the emfi as well with the same setup
um it also has a python library and API
so that's awesome
you could also even use a Raspberry Pi
Pico if you are fine with a more coarse
time scale it's the like work in
progress but I've had some good results
with it as well and of course it's
possibly less about five euros
um
and
I guess you can also overclock the
people so that's also something to look
into
um lastly you can use a cheap Whisperer
we have the uh the very latest version
here on the picture and it costs about
500 euros instead so
I think the PGA is the best and most
versatile option
for inducing the pulse you think I think
you have three options again
either you use the chip shorter which I
show in the top it's more on the
expensive side but it's nice and safe in
a modern case you could use the v-code
EMP which is open source again and much
more affordable
um although I like that the chip charger
goes to a higher voltage if you have
higher voltage you can make certain
pulses and since the lower voltage
doesn't discharges fast
and lastly we have a silicon coaster on
the picture which was developed by
Ledger and I know they always use this
in their presentations and their text
but unfortunately it's not open source I
mean there's a paper and I guess you
could build it yourself or anything
easily but it's not just pulling
resources from Department sending it to
an app
the good thing about this one is that it
goes to 750 volts so if you need that
maybe look into that or maybe modify the
people empty I guess
um I added a few custom things to the
setup as well which will be
um available online group first of all I
made a hardware reset
this is a nice PCB version of what I did
um earlier
it allows you to power the target to a
good power supply not like your USB but
for instance through a good linear level
Supply or the bearing jacket that's what
you have or even USB also and with just
a similar gpio from PGA or
microcontroller you can turn it on and
off and it's like very stupid thing but
from I was looking online I couldn't
find anything ready to go where
everybody but yeah I used it and I
didn't like this because the components
always fly out and you lose your wires
and your use the whole day because
jumper wires
so I guess it could be convenient for
different applications as well
I'm using this in connector for
everything this was motivated recording
of lens devices which also use the same
cables
and again the fpga records I will show
later what I'm using or what I used up
until now which is basically a
combination of two but this will be more
modular
and this is also just a trigger input
and the glitch output and then the delay
is done by the fpga also you have the
recent output that would be perfectly
suited to go into the hardware reset
as well as debug LEDs debug pins for
everything so
you can customize that to your liking
but modify by modifying the stream as
well right
and the software is
Emma EMF I control which I call it where
you can move around your device you can
move around
in a controlled manner you can prove
different things you can list your
devices and you can script this and this
then I used in my old campaign script
where I import it and yeah it's easier
to work right as well as the quality
Advanced script will write it also CSV
and then you can pass the CSV and
visualize your results as I mentioned
before you really want to do a map 2D
map so you can see whether you have some
outliers or you have some grouped faults
um on this target we have interestingly
it was more sensitive to crashes and
groundnuts in the exact area where I
also was able to get the glitches you
know it kind of makes sense
um
and um
yes as you can see a whole area is
affected right so basically
um the backlash and the accuracy of the
CNC isn't that problem because all those
yellow dots are all fine like all of
those work please give instructions
whatever mixed them
uh yeah here's again the the the the
power the hardware reset and the
glitching breakout two in one let's say
the bigger fpga but do not need that one
um
and in the back I have my my all the
hardware is at like it's it's messy so
I'm happy to have a new devices
um I tested the setup on a white modern
chip which you might all know
um it's supposed to be protected against
voltage Vault injection and there were
many results on three decisions of this
chip
um
and yeah they wanted to fix uh what it
called injection they wanted to fix side
channels but apparently emfi still works
um it also has CPU of secure Boot and
different other features that um should
all be applicable through the same
method
um yeah but first of all I will explain
how to characterize a chip for Falls
when you have it you want to get a test
test board a development board program
it with your custom firmware like a
simple loop as shown here the Apollo GP
are open high then you do 100 editions
of additions the same assembly
instructions over and over again and
then you you can pull it through again
and check the result
um
by placing the glitch in the middle it
should it should modify the results
right if it's successful if it's success
susceptible to glitching then the
results will change
um
there were a few uh challenges maybe to
keep in mind
um I did use the default tool chain so I
get the free rtos and all the
protections because I want to be as
close to the real world's deployed
devices as possible so it has Ronald
detection for instance these are not
dedicated but injection countermeasures
but there are safety Quantum measures
that make sure if your battery voltage
drops or something in this regard your
device will be reset instead of starting
to do wrong computations
um but of course it makes the glitching
a little bit harder
then such Loops as I described earlier
was just optimized away immediately so
you want to probably go inline assembly
and
let's see what also was funny this chip
has embedded uh to USB
and since USB SMS I mean your the a is
already asynchronous but if you send now
it sends no if you do USB you will never
know when it sends and it's falling all
the time and um
as we can see here I have my GPI open
high on the top then I have my on the
bottom line I have the the glitch pass
it's narrow but I hope you can see it
and the USB packets are just in the
middle like
fully out of place and it was corrupting
my communication
yeah many pitfalls
but in the end we got the instructions
more than one actually
it looks like the CPU or compute area of
the soc is in the top left I would like
to look into the chip into the die shots
as well but they don't exist yet and
that would be that would help to
identify where's my memory versus my Ram
is my CPU it's just once if you want
this chip
yeah and also another test which I don't
have a picture here you can see the
whole laptop corner is protected by
Brown art detection so it was giving me
Runners all the time with the wrong
parameters and they were defined
parameters I was getting this nice
yellow area
you also see the CSV visualized
um
where it's returning uh no nothing
happened 100 in most cases and then when
it glitch you will get the 99 98 97
something like that where you'll see
that the description of your
instructions
um
also sometimes School blocks right when
it got reset
there were also clock related crashes in
the center right area which was funny
because again I was getting good luck
all the time and I could see why it
crashes so maybe there's an oscillator
or something in that area
and again dry shots would help this is
just an example of a different chip
where you can see how random areas or
memory areas look very different from
Computing areas
and yeah
as of the about the impact and quoting
limited results from three years ago
he said there is no way to fix but you
can buy the neuter and I I don't think I
could put it any better
um
I mean yeah uh it's generally an
advanced attack
um so right now it's not something you
can do quickly in the field so if you
have some devices deployed somewhere it
might be simply outside of your attacker
model that someone goes there grabs it
you don't notice that you put it in the
left it's gone for days you don't notice
that either then if it's effect you
don't notice that you know that's the
question if it's in your hacker model
but um
um you should be aware that it is
possible to skip security features uh
skip code paths even if your code is
perfectly fine
um you might want to look into other
chips if you know that YouTube is
vulnerable the other chips may be more
secure against it
um maybe different architectures would
be better maybe faster maybe more course
it just makes it a bit harder to get it
done
um yeah it's the conclusion
um it's a very low cost mostly free open
source soft land Hardware
you need the XY stage for I guess about
200 dollars
you need the emfi posture it might cost
about 2 000 but you can again use a
vehicle EMP
and you need to take data generator for
about 100 Euros in the small pcbs and
Edge plus it's not much right
um so
I hope it's uh easy to see that it's not
that high of a hurdle or entry barrier
and it can even be improved with this
extra cost at all like using a 3D
printer or something well driven instead
of the CNC
um use a proper Hardware reset that
doesn't uh that that is reliable you
know you don't want it to reset your
target when it should
um and maybe you might need a higher
voltage plus I spoke about the people
yeah I haven't read it on this Target
but I it doesn't go as high with the
voltage and I did need the almost 500
volts from the Chip Shot on this target
so uh you if you don't get the results
you expect maybe it's very high I was
you just or a device that goes to higher
voltages
and lastly your device can be secure
against voltage volt injection against
side channels but like a serious
attacker like shown in the picture of
course we know they always look like
this I will always find a way and um
I guess this is also a invitation to
always try to find a way and also always
keep taking
um
yeah I have quite some time left so I'm
hoping for question and this policy
[Applause]
yes
yeah sure so the question was about how
to find the right delay
um basically the delay you want is of
course first and foremost post based on
when you or which instruction or which
feature you want to skip or glitch and
sometimes you can get like Source let's
say of the application or the bootload
or whatever you want this and you can
modify it to
add some gpios or hints like that right
before the important instructions and
you can time that with a scope and you
can also
uh check out the power signature em site
channels for instance if you are waiting
on some Crypt operation to happen on
boot you can see when it happens and on
your scope and you can use that as a
reference and then you want to just go a
bit earlier and then sweep a little bit
in the time domain yeah
foreign
yes
um
in a previous talk uh previous chips
from this uh Emily were successfully
glitched with different methods and they
said that the manufacturer told them
that new versions will be protected so I
thought let's look at the new versions
yeah yes in the back
[Music]
sequence are you able to like a compile
and run it or does it make a difference
if you run it in the application layer
and identify a region does it
necessarily apply to the the secure boot
let's say skipping the security measures
um yeah so since I was
um doing like a constructed example the
timing wasn't that essential and I was
mainly looking for the area and then
whether it's susceptible at all to this
attack
um so for applying this uh this
knowledge to a secure good for instance
which you mentioned uh you would have to
also find the timing but the area should
be mostly the same I guess the chip does
have uh crypto accelerators and
Equipment features and I guess those
might be in different areas of the soc
although in the end your application
code has to check the result like what
comes back it has to check that and that
might be in the same area again
do we have any other questions
no if no thank you
okay okay
uh I can tell you that
I I mean I can say about the disclosure
and stuff like uh I give the mini
picture a lot of information but I
didn't get the like okay we identified
and reproduced it so therefore I'm not
100 saying which model
yeah
thank you thank you very much